زميله نانسي محجوب في سوق واقف نانسي كما
ذكرت كلمه اليوم الطقس جميل اجواء رائعه
اليوم لدينا ثلاث مباريات نانسي وبالتالي
من من المتوقع ان نشهد زخما جماهيريا اكبر
خصوصا في منطقه حيويه مثل سوق واقف
[موسيقى]
نعم حمزه قبل ان ابدا بالحديث عن منطقه
سوق واقف والتي اصبحت بمثابه منطقه
الاحماء للجماهير التي تحضر كاس العالم
قبل التوجه الى ساحات الملاعب معي ضيف من
ايران فاستضيفه الان واتحدث معه عن حبوب
المنتخب الايراني في هذه البطوله همم
ااا نو ااه ساتحدث بالانجليزيه وساترجم لك
وللمشاهدين
هذا لونج لايت وكم اوفر هير تو سبورت
تورتين واتس يور اكسبكتيشن 4
سالته عن توقعاته بالنسبه لمباراه المنتخب
الايراني اليوم امام نظيره الانجليزيه
[تصفيق]
من المنتخب الايراني
امين
هذا الموسم
منتخب بلاده بالتاكيد كما يتمنى ذلك ولكن
يتوقع كما يتوقع الجميع حتى الان ان
المرشحين الاساسيين في هذه البطوله هما
المنتخب البرازيلي والمنتخب
قديشن
الى هنا
وللاستمتاع بالاجواء قبل الذهاب الى
الملعب ومشاهده منتخب ايران يلعب امام
الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]